Y
UNLIKELY FOR A SPECIAL MASTER,
BUT WE'LL BE WATCHING.
ALSO WATCHING A DEVELOPMENT AND
ITS IMPACT FROM PAST WEEK, THE
FIRM FACT THAT KIDS' SCORES FROM
ALL SORTS OF EDUCATIONAL TESTING
WERE IMPACTED BY ALL THAT TIME
DOING CLASSES FROM HOME.
IN FACT, ALL OF THEIR TEST
SCORES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
MARKEDLY SLIDING AND, IN FACT,
SOME OF THE LOWEST WE'VE SEEN IN
YEARS.
RYAN WALTERS IS THE OKLAHOMA
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION AND HAS
BEEN LOOKING AT THAT IMPACT AND
HOW TO TIE TO PREVENT IT IN THE
FUTURE.
SECRETARY, GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
THESE ARE PRETTY STARTLING
DEVELOPMENTS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THEM?
>> YES, SIR.
WHAT WE SAW HERE, NEIL, IS THE
NATIONAL TEACHERS UNIONS FAILED
OUR KIDS.
ANTHONY FAUCI FAILED OUR KIDS.
AND AT THE TIME, WE HAVE A GREAT
GOVERNOR HERE IN THE STATE OF
OKLAHOMA, GOVERNOR KEMP.
HIM AND I WERE OUT FRONT
DEMANDING SCHOOLS STAY OPEN
BECAUSE WE HEARD THESE
HEARTBREAKING STORIES FROM
AROUND THE STATE ON KIDS FALLING
BEHIND.
WE ALL KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN, BUT THE REALITY IS THE
NATIONAL TEACHERS UNION IS MORE
CONCERNED WITH POLITICS AND
POWER THAN THEY ARE OUR KIDS.
AND OUR KIDS NEEDED SCHOOLS TO
BE OPEN.
OUR PARENTS NEED MORE SCHOOL
CHOICE.
WE NEED IF MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO INSURE THAT MONEY IS
GETTING TO THE CLASSROOM SO THAT
EVERY ONE OF OUR KIDS CAN BE
CAUGHT UP TO BE WORK
FORCE-READY.
NEIL: WELL, I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
GOING FORWARD, SECRETARY, WHAT
YOU THINK WE SHOULD DO.
WE EVER HAVE ANOTHER INCIDENT
LIKE THIS, WHEN I HAD DR. FAUCI
ON THIS, HE THOUGHT THE SWEEPING
MEASURES IN RETROSPECT PROBABLY
SHOULD NOT BE TAKEN, AND I'M
WONDERING IF YOU'RE GETTING A
SENSE THAT WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
FROM COVID IS THAT WE
OVERREACTED.
DO YOU THINK WE SIMPLY
OVERREACTED AND IF SOMETHING
LIKE THAT WERE TO COME AGAIN, WE
DON'T DO THAT, WE DON'T SHUT
DOWN COMPLETELY, WE KEEP SCHOOLS
OPEN?
>> ABSOLUTELY, NEIL.
WE HAVE -- NOW KNOW DEFINITIVELY
IT WASN'T THE VIRUS THAT HAD
THIS MAJOR IMPACT ON KIDS, IT
WAS OUR REACTION TO THE VIRUS.
IT WAS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PUSHING SHUTDOWNS, IT WAS
ANTHONY FAUCI'S ORDERS, IT WAS
THE NATIONAL TEACHERS UNION
TELLING SCHOOLS TO CLOSE.
THE REALITY IS WE NOW KNOW THAT
SCHOOLS WERE SAFE.
WE NOW KNOW THAT OUR KIDS'
IMPACT, BECAUSE OF SCHOOL
SHUTDOWN, IS GOING TO BE
ENORMOUS.
SOME KIDS ARE YEARS BEHIND IN
ACADEMIC LEARNING.
IN THE FUTURE WHAT WE HAVE TO DO
IS WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE DONE ALL
ALONG, WE SHOULD RELY ON THE
STATES.
EDUCATION SHOULD BE LEFT TO THE
STATES, THE WAY THE SCHOOLS ARE
OPERATED.
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT'S BEST FOR
THEIR KIDS THAN THE MOM AND THE
DAD.
PARENT CHOICE IS SOMETHING WE'RE
PUSHING HERE IN OKLAHOMA.
IF PARENTS WANTED